- Your daughter Banks, she
also got a cool present, right,
for her birthday this year?
- She did.
- Yeah.
I mean, she got a lot of cool presents,
but I think the most exciting one for her,
is she's a massive Harry Styles fan.
- So is my son.
(audience member cheers)
- Okay, so, I mean, so am I.
- Me too.
- So when we bought the tickets,
I was like this is for me.
- Me too.
- Kinda like the hair tinsel.
- I got a full-on suite, girl.
I was like, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- It was so good.
And I have to tell you, Matt,
my husband watches a show.
Like just, I'm like, "are
you having a good time?
You enjoying this?"
And he's having the time of his life
but he's just like, absorbing
and like staring and like
and I'm like over here
like, "yeah we're partying.
I'm singing along."
And he's like,
- I'm singing and dancing.
- "I can't hear because
you're singing so loud and
embarrassing all of us."
And then Banks did the same thing.
And when we were driving I
thought she was gonna rip
her car seat out, she
was like, every word,
just like jamming so hard.
Wanted her window down, hair like flying
and then we got there and she was like-
- That's my son.
(audience laughing)
That's Remy.
- What's going on?
- He sat
and it was almost like, he was like,
"how do I memorize all these
moves so I can be him?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was like,
he was just watching like
so intently.
- Taking notes.
- So cute, yeah.